لوح رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي بن كاردن بتجميد
المساعدات العسكريه لمصر حتى تتخذ خطوات
لتحسين وضع حقوق الانسان واضاف كاردن انه
يتعين على القاهره تسريع اطلاق سراح
المعتقلين السياسيين وافساح المجال امام
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان ونشطاء المجتمع
المدني والمعارضه
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حيثيات واسباب
حجب جزء من المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لمصر وما هي الرسائل المراده من واشنطن
واي مخزن
لتوقيت كيف استقبلت القاهره هذا التوجه
والمطالبات الامريكيه وعلى اي نحو ستتفاعل
معه وما هي انعكاسات ذلك على مسار
العلاقات الامريكيه المصريه وعلى شكل
السياسات الخارجيه لاداره بايدن ازاء
القاهره خلال المرحله
[موسيقى]
المقبله لا مزيد من المساعدات العسكريه
دون تحسن ملموس في اوضاع حقوق الانسان في
مصر رساله حازمه جاه النائب بن كاردن
والسناتور جريجوري ميكس الى الحكومه
المصريه داعين البيت الابيض لاتخاذ ما
يلزم لحملها على تحسين سجلها في حقوق
الانسان كاردن اكد انه يعتزم ممارسه
مسؤوليات اللجنه الرقابيه وسلطاته بشكل
كامل لمنع التمويل العسكري الخارجي في
المستقبل ومبيعات الاسلحه للحكومه المصريه
وكان كاردن قد تولى رئاسه لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ بعد اتهامات
للسناتور بوب من
بتلقي رشا مقابل استغلال نفوذه لدعم
الحكومه المصريه في وجه الاتهامات لها
بانتهاكات واسعه وخطيره لحقوق
الانسان صحيفه نيويورك تايمز التي ذهبت
الى ان الاداره الامريكيه اعطت الاولويه
لمصالح الامن القومي الامريكي على حساب
حقوق الانسان قالت ان البيت الابيض وافق
على
235 مليون دولار من المساعدات العسكريه
للحكومه المصريه وهو المبلغ الذي كانت قد
حجبته خلال العامين الماضيين على خلفيه
سجل السلطات المصريه في حقوق الانسان
الصحيفه اكدت ان الولايات المتحده ستحجب
85 مليون دولار فقط من المساعدات العسكريه
المخصصه سنويا لدعم الجيش المصري واشارت
الصحيفه الى ان المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه السنويه المتبقيه البالغه 980
مليون دولار لا تخضع لشروط حقوق
الانسان
[موسيقى]
ا اناقش الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من فيرجينيا
جيم مورن عضو الكونجرس الامريكي السابق عن
الحزب الديمقراطي من واشنطن محمد المنشاوي
الكاتب الصحفي المتخصص بالشان الامريكي
ومن القاهره الكاتب الصحفي هشام يونس
مرحبا بكم جميعا سيد محمد اذا سيتم حجب
مبلغ 85 مليون دولار فقط من اصل 1.3 مليار
دولار المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه ل مصر
ما الرساله من هذا التهديد
بتقديرك ا تحيه طيبه عاهدت الادارات
الامريكيه على حجب جزء صغير من المعونه
العسكريه المقدمه لمصر والتي تبلغ مليار
و300 مليون دولار سنويا ربما 10% او 15% ا
تحت مشروطيه احترام حقوق الانسان
والانفتاح الديمقراطي في مصر وتتطلب
الميزانيه الامريكيه من وزير الخارجيه ان
يدلي بشهادته ويزيح هذه المشروطيه اذا راى
ان هناك ما يخدم مصالح الامن القومي
الامريكي ودابت الادارات الامريكيه
الجمهوريه والديمقراطيه كذلك على حجب ربما
100 مليون دولار فقط من اجمالي المبلغ وهو
رقم زهيد وبسيط جدا لا يؤثر على منظومه
التعاون العسكري الامريكي المصري ولا على
قوه العلاقات بينهما واشنطن دائما كان
عندها معضله ولانه زهيد سيد محمد نسال عن
عن الرساله
منه هناك هناك دائما تناقض وتضارب بين
مصالح الامن القومي الامريكي
ودعواتها التي اراها خطابيه لاحترام حقوق
الانسان والديمقراطيه في دولها الحليفه
الغير ديمقراطيه
مثل النظام المصري في هذه المرحله ودائما
تتغلب المصالح مصالح الامن القومي على
الدعايات حقوق الانسان والقيم الامريكيه
كما راينا خلال السنوات الاخيره وقبل
الربيع العربي وقبل
انهيار نظام مبارك ايضا هذه كانت معضله
دائمه ومستقره في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه ودائما تنتصر مدرسه الامن
القومي هناك لوبي لحقوق الانسان في واشنطن
ينشط وهذا هو مجال عمله ينشط من اجل دعم
الحريات و والديمقراطيه في الدول الحليفه
مثل مصر ويطالب بالضغط وهناك في اعضاء
المجلس النواب والشيوخ فئه صغيره جدا على
لا يعدوا على اصابع اليد الواحده يحاولون
الضغط على الحكومه لكن يفشلون دائما
وتتغلب المص العسكريه بين الدولتين سيد جم
انطلاقا من هذا الشرح للسيد محمد ما الذي
تطلبه الاداره الامريكيه من مصر فيما
يتعلق بملف حقوق
الانسان الحقيقه هي ان الولايات المتحده
قد قدمت لمصر 50 مليار دولار منذ اتفاقيه
السلام وقعت مع
اسرائيل ونحن نج
ان ان حقوق الانسان قد تدهورت خلال هذه
الفتره من الزمن ان الكونجرس الامريكي
اصدر
قانونا حصل على دعم من
الحزبين للقول ان
320 مليون من ال
1.3 مليار دولار التي نقدمها لمصر سنويا
ينبغي ايقافها حجبها اذا لم تحسن مصر
سجلها في مجال حقوق الانسان الجنرال سسي
قد حسن قد اعتقل اكثر من 65 الف شخص فقط
لاسباب سياسيه وارائهم السياسيه وهذا لا
يتوافق مع ما قاله الكونجرس وولايه
الكونجرس وان اداره بايدن الان تقول نحن
لن نحجب هذه 23 مليون دولار التي يريدها
الكونجرس بل سنعطي لمصر 230 الف نوقف ونحج
فقط 58 مليون السنتر كارتر و واعضاء اخرين
كبير كلهم محققون وكل ما يقولونه ان
الكونجرس
سوف يتحقق من سياسات المصر اذا لم تتحسن
في مجال حقوق الانسان فاي من هذه ال 230
مليون لنم يعطاه الى مصر سيحصلون فعلا على
مليار دولار بجميع الاوار وبالتالي
الكونغرس يفعل بالضبط
لاعل سيد هشام اذا المساعدات بمجملها تبلغ
1.3 مليار دولار مساعدات عسكريه سنويه
لمصر الحكومه المصريه كيف تنظر الى هذه
المساعدات بشكل عام بغض النظر عن ما يتم
الحديث عن حجمه الان كيف تنظر الى هذه
المساعدات هذا هذا الحجم الكبير من
المساعدات كيف تقيمها الحكومه
المصريه يعني اعتقد انه التقييم اللي
بيطلع على لسان مقربين من النظام بيقول
انه هي نسبه المساعدات كلها بتمثل 2% فقط
من الدخل القومي النائب مصطفى بكري وصل
وصف قبل كده حجب المساعدات بانه تلكيكه من
الاداره الامريكيه او ما وصفوا بتلك كه من
الاداره
الامريكيه
بسبب يعني دخول مصر فيما وصفوا ايضا
بمشاريع قوميه ووطنيه وما الى ذلك اعتقد
انه الامر
يعني مستمر منذ
2014 حجب بعض المساعدات او التهديد
بحجبها لكن انا اعتقد انه الامر يبدو لي
رمزي فقط و يعني ليس حقيقيا لا فيما يتعلق
باهتمام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمجال
حقوق الانسان ولا
بانه يعتبر هذه الخطوه تهديد حقيقي الدليل
على ذلك انه في العام
الماضي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اوقفت 130 مليون دولار
من المساعدات العسكريه لكنها عملت صفقه زي
ما وصفتها نيوورك تايمز ب 20 ضعف صفقه
سلاح ب 20 ضعف هذا المبلغ النقطه الثانيه
انه في قيود على النسبه الاكبر من
المساعدات لا تضع علها قيود فيما يتعلق
بحقوق الانسان مش بس في مصر في مصر ودول
اخرى انه في نسبه كبيره من الاموال
والمساعدات لا تخضع للتقويم مهما كان
السجل متدهور او او سيء بما معناه انه
الاداره الامريكيه تختار ما يناسب سياسات
تخدم الولايات المتحده فقط بصرف النظر عن
ملف حقوق الانسان اللي يعني هو ملف جدلي
طب نقطه مهمه اع سيد جيم اذا كانت مصر
تقول بان هذا ليس له اي علاقه بملف حقوق
الانسان وبان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
غير مهتمه بهذا الملف اذا ما الذي سيجعل
الحكومه المصريه تتخذ اجراءات لتتطابق مع
ما يقول كونجرس بانه مطالب لتحسين ملف
حقوق
الانسان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه و
كونجرس الذي يمثلها يهتم تتمون فعلا بحقوق
الانسان لانهم يعلمون بان حقوق الانسان
جزء لا يتجزا من الامن القومي هذه
سياستنا على الشركات تطبق وتحترم حقوق
الانسان ستكون اكثر امانا وضمانا ونحن
كذلك والقول بان هذه مجرد شيء رمزي كلا لا
اعتقد لا
اعتقد ان هذا وصف دقيق تماما هذا يبعث
برساله
رساله الى مصر باننا جادو ونريد من
الجنرال السيسي ان يحترم بعض من قيمنا نحن
لان هذه اموال دافعيه ضرائب الامريكان
التي ترسل اليهم 50 بليار دولار لمصر منذ
عام
1979 وبالتالي لابد ان يحترم بشكل كبير
قيمنا
نحن اعتقد ان ذلك ينبغي ان يطبق على كل
مبلغ واحد 1.3 مليار دولار و وما نتكلم عن
الموضوع ربما علينا ايضا نطبق بعض اجراءات
المسائله بالنسبه للاموال اللي ترسل الى
اسرائيل الذي هو مبلغ اكبر بكثير كل من
هذا كل من هذين التمويل بدا عام
1979 وضع مصر ازداد سوءا وحتى اسرائيل
اصبحت اقل اسرائيل اصبحت اقل احترامها
للديمقراطيه وايضا فيما يتعلق بتعاملها مع
الشعب الفلسطيني علينا انكون متوازنين في
سياساتنا و وانا اعتقد ان سن كاردر وكثير
من مجلس النواب فعلا متوافقون في ذلك كما
ان نبحث رساله بان مصر لا ينبغي ان
تقدم رشا لسيناتور في الولايات المتحده
لتحصل على مت المساعدات هذا خطا اذا هذا
الامر هذا امر مهم جدا سيد محمد هل واشنطن
جاده بهذه التهديدات تجاه مصر فيما يتعلق
بملف حقوق
الانسان لا على الاطلاق الخبره التاريخيه
خلال السنوات الاخيره وقبل الاخيره منذ
معاهده السلام وحتى الان اثناء حكم مبارك
وما بعده حتى الان يؤكد ان الولايات
المتحده لا تكترس بقضايا حقوق الانسان
والديمقراطيه في مصر طالما هناك اعتبارات
هامه للامن القومي كما تراه واشنطن هناك
لوبيات تدعم هذه الفرديه هنا في واشنطن
شركات السلاح الامريكي التي تتعاون مع مع
الجهات المصريه ومع الدول الحليفه الاخرى
غير الديمقراطيه تضغط بشده على الكونجرس
وتقول له ان هناك فرص وتسريح العماله
سيحدث اذا اغلق هذا المصنع الذي يصدر هذه
قطع السلاح الى الى مصر او دول اخرى غير
ديمقراطيه في المنطقه فاعتقد ان
الديمقراطيه المصريه ليست هدف للاداره
الامريكيه هذه الاداره او الادارات الاخرى
الجمهوريه والديمقراطيه كما راينا على
مدار التاريخ الامريكي الحديث هم فقط
يتحدثون عن هذه القيم والمبادئ لكن لا
ياخذون اي خطوات فعليه لدعم هذه الاجنده
اجنده الديمقراطيه في في مصر او في اي
دوله اخرى في المنطقه طالما ان هذا قد
يهدد المصالح الامريكيه واشنطن تحب
التعامل مع ديكتاتوريات في المنطقه بدلا
من حكومات منتخبه تكون لها مسائله امام
شعوبها وهذا غير موجود للاسف في المنطقه
العربيه ومصر تحديدا السيد هشام كيف يمكن
ان تتفاعل الحكومه المصريه مع هذه
التهديدات خاصه بان هناك
عددا من المشرعين الامريكيين ينخرطون في
مطالب لمسائل الحكومه المصريه فيما يتعلق
بملف حقوق
الانسان يعني الحق انه زي ما قلت سابقا
انه التهديدات وقطع وحجب جزء من المعونه
العسكريه مستمر
بشكل متكرر منذ 2014 هذا ليس بالامر
الجديد
وهناك ايضا يعني زي ما حضرتك قلت في مقدمه
التقرير
انه تايمز نشرت انه
235 تم حجبهم في العامين الماضيين تم
ارسالهم ايضا انا يعني ده بيقول انه حتى
لو حصل مش حجب بقى تاخير يمكن في
المساعدات لكن انا بتفق مع الصديق الاستاذ
محمد المنشاوي فيما يتعلق بعدم جديه
الولايات المتحده في هذا الموضوع وال
الامر المهم في او النقطه المهمه في هذا
السياق انه هذه المساعدات ليست اموالا
سائله تضخ مباشره الى الخزانه المصريه
ولكنها عقود سلاح وذخيره ومدات عسكريه وما
الى ذلك والنقطه الثانيه اذا كان صحيحا ما
يقال عن ملف حقوق الانسان في الولايات
المتحده ان هو ان هو حاكم بالنسبه
للمعونات في الولايات المتحده فاين تخفيض
المساعدات فيما يتعلق بانتهاك حقوق
الفلسطينيين على كل الاصعده في الضفه
والقطاع وايضا داخل الخط الاخطر بالنسبه
لما تفعله
اسرائيل يعني لم نسمع ابدا اي احد يتحدث
هذا ليس معناها انني اتحدث عن وضع جيد
لحقوق الانسان في مصر لكنني اتحدث عن عدم
جديه الولايات المتحده في او عدم ما
يمكنني ان ان اؤمن باخلاقي ما تقول
الولايات المتحده وجديته في ملف حق
الانسان واشار السيد جيم قبل قليل الى هذه
النقطه تحديدا التعامل مع اسرائيل سيد جيم
بن كاردن تحدث عن ما سماها مسؤولياته
وسلطه لجنه الشؤون الخارج لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في الكونغرس لمنع التمويل
العسكري مستقبلا انت كعضو سابق في
الكونجرس هل لدى هذه اللجنه قدره على وقف
تمويل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاي جهه
ما وهنا المق طبعا حجب مساعدات عسكريه
لمصر على خلفيه ملف حقوق الانسان نريد ان
نفهم ما هي سلطه هذه اللجنه على الحكومه
الامريكيه نعم سيدم السؤال
لك لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه وكذلك مجلس شيخ
ومجلس النواب لديهم سلطات
كبيره فوج القانون هم يقرون ترسل لمن ليست
الاداره ان دستورنا ينص على
ان المشرعون المنتخبون في مجلسي الشيوخ
والنواب هم يقرون منهم حلفائنا والكثير من
الادارات ومسؤوليه الاداره الامريكيه هي
تنفيذ ما يقرره ويشرع الكونجرس اداره
بايدن خاطئه باستخدام قوط سلطاتها
باعطاء 135 مليون دولار الى مصر في حين ان
الكونجرس قال كلا اذا الكونغرس يؤكد
صلاحيته وقوله فاذ لديهم الصلاحيه وسلطه
وقد سمعنا قبل قليل ان الحكومه كانت على
مشكل اغلاق لانها لم تستطيع الاتفاق لم
يست الاتفاق على النفقات ان الاداره لا
تستطيع ان تنفق دولارا واحدا الا اذا وافق
الكونجرس على ذلك واذا وافق الكونجرس
الاداره كما هنا في حال حال اداره كونغرس
فهذه لابد يقولون للاداره كيف الاموال
الموافقه عليها واداره بايتن مخطئه اذا ما
حاولت ان تستخدمها بطريقه مختلفه عن ما
قاله الكونجرس الكونغرس يقول الان مره
اخرى داردن كلا كلا انتم تنفذون ما قلنا
لكم نحن قلنا لكم لان الجن السيسي لا يحقق
تقدم في مجال حقوق الانسان فهو لا ينبغي
ان يحصل اي من هذا المبلغ ال 135 مليون
اذا اداره بايدن عليها تنفذ ذلك سيكون
عليها سحب كلامها
تغيير سياستها وحجم هذا المبلغ لان المجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ تحدثا وهذا بطريقه
اتفاق الحزبين على الامر وهم واضحون في
ذلك وعلى اداره بايدن ان ينفذوا ما وصل
اليهم من اوامر وتعليمات سيد هشام الحكومه
المصريه وفي ردها على هذه الاتهامات
تربط دائما ما بين ملف حقوق الانسان وما
تسميها الحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار في في
مصر كيف ترى هذا الربط من الحكومه
المصريه يعني هو الحقيقه يعني ا الحديث عن
ملف حقول الانسان في
مصر يعني تتلقاه الحكومه المصريه والنظام
في مصر بحساسيه شديده ا يمكني القول ايضا
انه من
خلال يعني ما لمسناه فيما مرحله ما بعد
الحوار الوطني ربما هناك تحسن بسيط لكن
الحكومه المصريه دابت ايضا على الا او الا
تبدو تبدو انها لا تخضع للضغوط فيما يتعلق
بهذا الملف وربما بتصبر حتى في حاله الضغط
الافراج عن احد النشطاء او احد السجناء
بعينه تنتظر بضع شهور ثم تقوم بالافراج
عنه لكي لا يبدو ان هناك استجابه فوريه في
هذا الملف يعني لا تحدث استجابات فوريه
وهناك حساسيه في تلقي او الاستجابه لما
يبدو انها ضغوط في هذا وربما تكون هناك
اتفاقات على تاخير امر ما
ثم الاستجابه له فيما بعد لكن الخطاب
الاعلامي طبعا ما بتكونش في هناك ردود
رسميه الى حد كبير لكن الخطاب الاعلامي
اللي بتمثله
الدوائر المقربه من الحكومه ودوائر
الاعلام بين قوسين كده شبه الرسمي ان هو
طبعا بيبقى خطاب غاضب
وخطاب رافض وبيعتبر انه هذا
تحريض ضد الحكومه وضد النظاام في مصر
وبترفع شعارات الوطنيه والقوميه
والاستقلال وما الى ذلك وه ربما شعارات لا
ترفع في ملاحي اخرى او مجالات اخرى تستلزم
الحديث عن استقلاليه القرار وعدم التبعيه
سييد محمد بتقديرك ما افاق هذه الازمه بين
الكونجرس والحكومه المصريه انطلاقا من ملف
حقوق الانسان وحجب جزء من المساعدات
اعتقد ان ان ملف حقوق الانسان واستدعاء
الكونجرس له ليس بجديد كما ذكرت هذا روتين
يقوم به الكونجرس منذ عشرات السنين في
العلاقه المصريه الامريكيه لكن الجديد هو
الاتهامات التي نالت رئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ مؤخرا السناتور
روبرت من دينيز واحتمال تلقي رشا من رشاوي
من الحكومه المصريه للتاثير على زملائه
وعلى وربما تسليب معلومات للاجهزه
الاستخباريه المصريه هذه فضيحه من العيار
الثقيل وهناك تحقيق جنائي بدا في في
فيدرالي بدا في ولايه نيويورك وتتدخل في
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الاف بي اي
واعتقد ان ما قام
به السناتور الذي بن كارد الذي حل محل من
دينيز في مطالبه بوقف هذه المساعدات
المتوقعه لمصر يدخل في هذا الاطار الاعم
من هذه الفضيحه وتبعتها السياسيه وهناك
تحقيق جنائي كما ذكرت واذا تم اتهام او او
اثبات التهم على السناتور من دينيز ستكون
هناك هزه كبيره جدا داخل واشنطن وعلى
العلاقات المصريه الامريكيه لكن من حسن حظ
القاهره ان واشنطن لا تكترس ولا تهتم
كثيرا بالعلاقه مع القاهره خلال السنوات
الاخيره هناك لاعبون اقوى واهم في المنطقه
تركز عليها اداره رئيس بايدن مثل ملف
التطبيع السعودي الاسرائيلي الذي اصبح هو
الشغل الشاغل لها في الشرق الاوسط والدول
الاخرى والقضايا الاخرى مثل حقوق الانسان
او العلاقات مع مصر هي قضايا هامشيه لا
يهتم بها الكثيرون في
واشنطن سريعا سيد جم لو سمحت اجمعت على ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رغم
الانتقادات الواسعه لملف حقوق الانسان ال
انها تساعد الحكومه المصريه والجيش المصري
ما حسابات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
هذا باقتضاب لو
سمحت ما تقوله صحيح الولايات
المتحده قد دربت
و المعدات للجيش المصري لكن مع الاسف
الجيش المصري استخدم هذه المعدات والتدريب
لقا مع مواطنيهم 6 الف سجين سياسي هم
حاليا يقمعون في السجون وهذا امر خاطئ ولا
يتوافق مع السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
وبالتالي اذا كان الجنرال سيسي يريد هذه
الاموال فعليه ان يفهم ان هذا ليس شك على
بياض بل لن نعطي اموال عندما نعطي اموال
لمصر فان نتوقع شيء مقابل ذلك وما نتوقعه
هو ان يكون محترما ومطيعا لقانون عالمي
بان الافراد ينبغي دهم حق التعبير عن
ارائهم والافراد يكم حق في الحياه وان
يعيش بحريه وبسعاده هذا ما نؤمن به نحن
ولكنه قيم عالميه دوليه ثك الجنر السيسي
اما يقبلها ذا قبلها فنعطيه كل ما يحتاجه
من اموال شكرا لكم السيد جيم مورن عضو
الكونجرس الامريكي السابق محمد المنشاوي
الكاتب الصحفي في واشنطن وهشام يونس
الكاتب الصحفي في القاهره الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
المتابعه الى اللقاء بامان الله
[موسيقى]
ورع
ه